Narrator: The show that
revolutionized business is back.
In eight years,
with over $87 million invested
in the Tank thus far,
Shark Tank businesses
have generated
hundreds of
millions in sales...
Even you couldn't have predicted
this kind of breakout success.
No, but it's taught all of us
what a platform "Shark Tank" is.
...employed thousands...
Lepage:
You're creating great jobs
for the people
in the state of Maine.
So keep them coming.
... and changed how America
does business.
President Obama: We have a lot
of brainpower here.
We even got a few Sharks.
"Shark Tank"'s become
an American phenomenon,
and the support of the President
just goes to show you
that the American dream
is alive and well.
Narrator:
From their humble beginnings,
the Sharks are all self‐made
and understand what it takes
to build business empires
from nothing.
And now they're here to help
other entrepreneurs
realize their dreams.
You guys are the American dream
come true.
You are why I do this show.
Narrator: Together they've
created monster successes...
Krause: Lori helped me get
into every Bed Bath & Beyond,
and now we've topped $85 million
in sales.
Narrator: ... and impacted
the world for the better.
Melissa: We were able to take
100 kids off the streets.
We chased our dreams, and now
we're seeing them come true.
The power of "Shark Tank"
is back.
Woman:
This has been a long road
and a lot of hard work,
and it's all coming true.
Some businesses are born in
hell, and this is one of them.
Ohh.
[ Crying ] It's just hard to go
through all of this.
This is
just the beginning.
Narrator:
And it all begins now.
It's not for the meek.
It's not for the weak.
‐You did it.
‐Whoo!
We got a deal!
I'm gonna suck in my gut
the whole time.
That's the last thing you got
to worry about, bro.
I know.
I'm just saying.
Narrator:
First into the tank
is an affordable solution
to a formal‐wear need.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks,
I'm Sebastian.
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Raul.
Both: And we are the creators
of The Lapel Project.
We're seeking $150,000
for 20% of our company.
Sharks, we have created a
game‐changing fashion accessory
that will revolutionize
the fashion world,
disrupting
the tuxedo industry,
leaving them sleepless
at night.
You know, special events ‐‐
They do happen all the time.
Proms, weddings, formals,
black‐tie events ‐‐
They happen
across the globe.
Cost you, if not hundreds,
thousands of dollars,
for something that
you'd only wear once,
collecting dust
in your closet?
And renting for one night
burns a hole in your pocket.
You know, it just causes
such an inconvenience,
getting fitted,
returning, picking up.
I mean, who's got time
for all of that?
No one does.
Introducing...
The Lapel Project.
The Lapel Project allows
you to customize
any suit jacket
into a tuxedo in seconds.
[ Laughter ]
No longer are you
gonna have to go out,
rent, or purchase
another tuxedo again.
Oh, my. [ Laughs ]
Choose from
an unlimited array
of fabrics, designs,
and patterns,
limited only
by your imagination.
Let me show you
how it works.
We simply adhere it
to the exterior of the lapel.
[ Laughs ]
Greiner: [ Chuckles ]
It's press‐and‐stick.
‐Cuban: Oh, I want one.
‐Fold over the excess.
‐I want one.
‐And in seconds,
you have a one‐of‐a‐kind
conversation piece.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐You sure do.
You would
so wear this, Mark.
In a heartbeat.
Now this is definitely
one‐of‐a‐kind.
Our lapels have even evolved
into a branding tool,
marketing tool, as well
as a fashion accessory.
You see, Sebastian
is standing here
with a beautiful
burgundy suit,
which we're
bringing over,
and we've
chosen our top seller,
which is just a standard
satin black lapel, okay?
Simply follow the lines
of the suit lapel,
fold over the excess,
and in seconds,
we've created
a fashion accessory.
Wow, it actually looks
really good.
It does.
We've created
a one‐of‐a‐kind tuxedo.
Ba‐bam!
Sharks, this has
no predecessors.
This is completely new.
This is the evolution
of men's fashion.
I lo‐‐
Since you're dressed
to invest...
let's make a deal.
‐I like it.
‐You want to try it?
Yeah, you got to bring us
the samples.
Sebastian's got
some cuts of lapels,
which we've made
for all of you guys.
‐Okay, let's try the ‐‐
‐Save the skulls for me.
‐Try the skulls.
‐I want the skulls.
♪♪
Garcia: So, you fold over the
excess neatly, and in seconds,
you have a custom,
one‐of‐a‐kind piece.
These are
blank canvases, guys.
There's no sewing involved.
‐Greiner: I have a question ‐‐
‐I have something for you, too.
‐Do you have anything for me?
‐Yes, I do.
I'm feeling lonely here.
I know you don't wear
jackets often,
so I got you a nice,
little jacket for you
I want you to try on for me,
please.
Okay.
And again, this can be
a woman's accessory, as well.
We all know suit lapels
for women and men...
[ Laughter ]
...come in notched
and come in peaked.
Look up for me, please.
Thank you very much.
John: Hey, buddy,
watch that hand.
[ Laughter ]
And in seconds, look how
beautiful that is.
Lori, going out to the club
tonight?
[ Laughter ]
The clown look is more you.
‐Good luck with that.
‐Okay, cool.
‐All right.
O'Leary:
All right, many questions.
First question is,
I take it out tonight.
I look spectacular.
I want to use it again.
Do I remove it,
put it on back to the paper,
and can I use it again,
or do I have to throw it out
and buy a new one?
No, you can definitely use it
again up to 5 to 10 times,
depending on how
you take care of it.
Does it ruin any different types
of fabrics or materials?
Absolutely not. I've personally
ruined several suits
finding the right application,
the right adhesive.
But I knew I was onto something,
so I just continued with it.
How much is it, Sebastian?
Our cost
is between $5 to $8.
Both:
And what do you sell it for?
We sell it between
$49 to $100.
‐Whoa!
‐How do you sell it?
We sell it right now
in one brick‐and‐mortar
store in South Florida.
Together:
That's it?
‐That's it.
‐What about the online business?
We haven't gone there yet,
and that's why we're here.
We need the money
to set up our e‐commerce.
This is a brand‐new product
that no one knows about.
‐Hang on.
‐We need to inform the public.
How did you find this one store
in South Florida?
That's my store.
I grew up in the business.
I was gonna say
you own it.
I grew up
in the business.
‐So, what are your sales?
‐Right now, from six months,
I started doing
the manufacturing ‐‐ $16,000.
Do you have some kind
of a patent?
How are you gonna
protect this?
I have
a patent pending, yes, sir.
On the design patent?
I have a utility patent
on the function.
No, a utility patent
on the function
of converting a suit
into a tuxedo.
Is your idea
that it's a gag gift?
‐No, absolutely not.
‐Absolutely not.
‐Oh, come on.
‐Oh, are you kidding me?
‐To proms and stuff?
‐I see that Kevin ‐‐
Robert, Robert, neckwear sales
have dropped 25%.
I mean,
I see the fun gag.
Sebastian, what guy out there
is gonna put this on
and go
to a formal event?
Me.
It all depends
on the personality.
‐Me!
‐You're at Palm Beach.
‐But you won't put on a suit.
Guys ‐‐
I'm gonna walk into
the White House like this.
You would never do that!
In a heartbeat.
‐You would not.
‐In a heartbeat.
Robert, my target demographic
is ages between 13
to young adults ‐‐ 35.
People who need to go
to prom ‐‐
Renting will cost you anywhere
between $200, $250
of used,
ill‐fitting clothing.
You guys own
this company?
I'm gonna wear this
to my wedding now.
Garcia: There's never been
a third option.
There's an instant demand
for this.
I'm on the front lines
of this business.
I deal with people on
a daily basis with that dilemma.
"Do I buy, or do I rent?"
I show them this product,
and they're in complete
amazement and awe.
Sebastian, you've got
a lot of energy.
You've got a lot of energy.
You're kind of like
one of those guys
I'm worried you're just
gonna burst into flames.
Cuban: That's okay.
So, hold ‐‐ hold on, Sebastian.
Let me ask Sebastian ‐‐
Are you a pain ‐‐ Are you a pain
in the ass to work with?
Absolutely not.
[ Laughter ]
I have a vision in this.
I see this.
‐But you had to think about it.
‐Sebastian! Sebas‐‐
Some of my employees
may say differently.
‐Sebastian.
‐Yes, sir?
‐Business right here.
‐Yes, sir.
Okay, I love it. I mean, the
things I could do with sports,
you know, with kids,
the online component.
I have Amazon exclusives
just in my name,
where they would
turn it around.
It would crush it.
So, what I'll do ‐‐
I'm gonna make you an offer ‐‐
150K for 30%.
O'Leary: Wait a minute.
Let me tell you
where I stand on this.
Wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait.
Attention on me.
‐Yes, sir.
‐Attention on me.
You want to get
other offers, don't you?
‐Wait! Wait!
‐I'm gonna share my thoughts.
‐Yes.
‐Hold on, hold on.
You're gonna lose the deal,
Sebastian.
‐I'm not losing the deal.
‐You are gonna lose the deal.
If you want to, you know, mess
around with these guys.
Don't you want to hear
other offers?
John: Hold on.
Hold on one second.
You know, you sold $16,000
worth, and I'll tell you why.
People love you, right?
You sold it out of your store.
Your store's probably
been there.
It's probably a mainstay
in the community.
People know where
they need to go,
and you are
the best salesman ever.
‐Thank you.
‐You really are.
But in all
my fashion companies,
we used to always make coats
that you can flip inside‐out.
So obviously, reversibles.
People generally don't use
these functionalities.
I have a history of not seeing
these type of things utilized,
even though
they may be purchased.
So I'm out.
I respect your decision.
I respect your experience.
Obviously a lot more
than I have.
‐Greiner: Wait, wait, wait.
‐But I made you an offer!
I get ‐‐ I get the whole thing
about the lapels
that you're wearing for people
who can't afford to,
don't want to buy a tux.
But I do not like
the look of this.
What?!
As a woman, I would
not be digging this.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Guys, either we're doing
a deal, or we're not.
So, guys, it's
a little sobering
that the fashion guru
and the only woman Sharkette
concerned about this ‐‐
Well, what if I was a kid,
and I was going to the prom?
I got to get this girl
to go out with me.
Mark, we're gonna
take your deal, sir.
We're gonna take
your deal, Mark.
Thank you!
‐[ Laughs ]
‐There you have it.
Thank you very much.
‐My pleasure.
‐Pleasure.
‐Yeah.
‐We'll crush it.
‐Thank you.
‐All right, guys.
‐Let's do it.
Thank you for your time.
‐Thank you, guys.
‐Good luck, you guys.
‐Good luck, guys.
[ Both laugh ]
Cuban:
I'm telling you when I take my
son to a wedding or something
and you put the little
baby suit he has on
and you put the bride and groom
on there, right?
Yeah, and then he goes
to the bathroom,
and he comes out
looking like this.
Are you sure your son's
gonna like that?
‐So what? So what?
‐[ Laughs ]
That's another use.
We're gonna charge extra
for that.
It's actually a testament
that you can really do ‐‐
If you work hard
towards your dreams
and you work towards it
every single day,
no matter what little,
small step you do,
but you do one small step every
day, you can make it happen.
You just got to
believe in it.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a solution
to a decorating dilemma.
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Leslie Pierson.
I'm from Seattle, Washington,
and my product is called
GoodHangups.
I'm looking for $100,000 for a
10% equity stake in my business.
Sharks, I have commitment
issues... with decorating!
I want to be free to hang things
on my wall.
But sometimes
I just can't fathom
putting one more hole
in my wall.
I've tried alternatives
like putties.
They don't work.
I've tried tacks and tape,
but they damaged
my treasured artwork.
Well, GoodHangups fixes
all of those hangups and more.
GoodHangups
is a revolutionary product
that turns your wall
into a magnet board.
They're super‐easy to use.
Place the magnetic‐receptive
sticker on the wall.
Place your art...
‐Oh, Lord.
‐Very attractive.
And add the magnets.
It's that easy.
Hmm!
O'Leary: Yes!
[ Laughter ]
They're removable and reusable,
and they work
on tons of surfaces,
like concrete, brick, tile,
wood, and textured walls.
So, Sharks, who wants to get
hung up on GoodHangups?
‐Do you have any to pass out?
‐I sure do!
[ Laughs ]
I like her 'cause she's
low‐energy.
[ Chuckles ] That's what
everybody always says about me.
‐Thank you.
‐There you go, Lori.
Thank you.
Leslie, I take this off,
and I stick it
with the little magnetic piece
to the wall.
‐Yeah.
‐Does it damage the wall?
No, it won't damage your walls.
They're removable and reusable.
I have some that I've reused
many, many times.
They're really, really great.
It's an adhesive that's actually
sticking it, right?
It is adhesive.
Many people would just fold
a piece of Scotch tape in half
and get both adhesive sides.
‐Isn't that the same effect?
Well, no, because
if you put that on the wall
and wait a week, you're actually
gonna get a stain.
Greiner:
You're gonna get a stain.
So, do you have a significantly
different adhesive?
Yes, we do.
Is part of your claim that
no matter what you put it on,
it's gonna remove it without
damage, even a month later?
Even a month later.
Even a year later.
What are your sales?
So, the product's been out
about a year,
and I've sold a little
over $450,000 in sales.
Good for you.
That's good.
‐That's not bad.
‐Thank you.
That's really good.
Where did you sell
your $450,000?
Over 50% has been on QVC.
I know.
I recognized this.
You've been on QVC?
You recognized me?
How did you come up
with this idea?
Well, I came up with it
because I have a 5‐year‐old
who is super‐creative.
He was bringing home
tons of art.
The fridge was fully covered,
and I knew there had to be
a better way.
And literally, if there was
another solution on the market,
I would have bought it
and been done.
You wouldn't see me here
at all
because I just needed
to solve my problem.
So, of the $450,000 in sales,
what amount is QVC?
What amount is non‐QVC?
Yeah, a little over half
is QVC.
The rest of it comes
from a combination
of either direct sales.
About 20%
come direct, retail.
‐Which retailer?
‐What retail are you in?
So, we're currently sold
in over 110 paper‐source stores
nationwide.
What about Staples?
We're not there yet.
We'd love to be there.
Leslie, what does it sell for?
And what's your cost?
We sell these
in 8, 16, 40, and 100 pack.
What does the 8‐pack
sell for?
The 8‐pack sells for $14.99.
My cost of goods is $2.25.
Nice!
Landed here. I'm assuming
you make them offshore.
No, we are U. S.‐made,
U. S. and imported parts.
What do you need
the money for today?
I'm a super‐fan
of you guys.
I've watched you
for seven years,
and I feel like you've been
my silent partners on this.
Okay, enough sucking up.
[ Laughs ]
I know. I am.
So, I'm really here
for the strategic partnerships.
What element of strategy
do you need help with?
First off, opening up
larger big‐box retailers.
The big thing is conveying
in a retail store
how this works, right?
Because you ‐‐
Exactly.
This is my biggest challenge.
I'm not sure
the packaging does that.
Seeing it up there, it wasn't
clear what the benefit was.
I 100% agree there's opportunity
to tweak the packaging.
That is why I'm probably
the most nervous
about going in big‐box stores
is that if it doesn't sell
through, I got one shot at it.
Leslie, I'll get
the ball rolling.
I think
it's a great product.
‐Okay.
‐Congratulations.
‐Thank you.
‐450K doing all this.
You're a force of nature.
‐Wow.
But in terms of trying to take
a force of nature
and turn that into a company
and get through all
the blocking and tackling,
I don't think I'm the
best‐suited person for that.
I'm out.
Mark is right.
You are a force of nature.
You have such an incredibly
pleasant personality,
and you have
all the right answers.
It's fantastic.
Look, when I was
a little kid,
somebody made me cut
between the lines
and they moved stuff up
on the wall and I messed it up
and the other kids
made fun of me.
It's a horrible memory.
‐Aw.
‐Ohh!
I'm just not the arts‐crafts
kind of guy.
Not for me. I'm out.
So, I can see you have, like,
crazy drive, like I do.
And there is no force equal,
in my mind, to a woman
that's determined to rise.
So I'm gonna give you
an offer.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm gonna give you $100,000,
but it would be for 20%.
I think I can help you get
into Bed Bath & Beyond
and Staples and all the places
where this needs to go.
You all have superpowers.
If there was actually
an opportunity
to get a super team
going...
‐Lori is not enough for you?
‐I'll tell you what I'll do.
Lori knows ‐‐ She's Queen
of QVC, Queen of Retail.
Just to give ‐‐ Leslie, I'll
give you some leverage.
But I'll tell you, Leslie,
you'll have to tell me now
because I can see
what this is like here.
Leslie, do you want to hear
another offer or not?
Lori, in the adhesive space,
who's the number‐one maker?
I'd like you to answer now.
‐Lori. Lori.
‐Wait, wait, do not do that
because it'll give you
some leverage.
Don't do that.
‐Your packaging...
‐Yeah.
‐...needs a lot of help.
‐I'm open.
You know what?
And that's
my sweet spot, so...
I'd like to make sure that
I hear all the offers first.
‐Well...
‐I want you to know
that I will not make a rash
decision when we're partners.
She is a sweet talker.
Wow!
You are good!
It's all smart stuff,
but do you feel I'm the right
partner for you?
‐You know, so, I'm doing it ‐‐
‐I'm so surprised by this.
Leslie, you either have to take
my offer or it may go away.
Leslie, do you want to hear
other offers or not?
Narrator:
Two Sharks are out.
Leslie has one offer
on the table from Lori
for her magnetic picture hangers
GoodHangups.
But she may jeopardize the deal
by waiting to hear
from Kevin and Daymond.
Lori, I 100% agree you are
the right partner for me.
I do need to hear out
the room.
‐Bird in the hand.
‐You do.
‐It is. It is. It is.
‐Bird in the hand!
It is, but believe me, Lori,
I'll make this work.
‐Leslie, I'm gonna give you ‐‐
‐Leslie! Leslie! Leslie!
I'll give you $100,000 for 15%.
‐Whoa!
‐$100,000 for 15%.
I want to take this to ShurTech,
the people who make Duck Tape.
I want to give you
some leverage.
I want you to squeeze her down.
I'm gonna do this favor for you.
I know the president of Staples
and the CEO.
‐We all do.
‐But wait.
‐So what?
Also, I think
this would work.
Going back to Shutterfly,
who bought GrooveBook...
Perfect add‐on,
don't you think?
I did $38,000 a minute with them
two weeks ago on QVC.
And every time he goes on,
the stock price goes down.
I also did cupcakes
at $38,000 a minute.
So please stop
talking about it.
I did $40,000 in ‐‐
Kevin, is there
an offer coming?
Yeah, are you
doing an offer?
I want you to go with Lori
'cause I think you're great,
but I'll do $100,000 for 10% so
you can drive her price down.
Wow, you're giving her exactly
what she's asking for.
Yes. I'll do it.
But you want her
to go with Lori?
I'll do it for 10%, but I want
you to squeeze her head.
Cuban: [ Laughs ]
So, just to ‐‐
Leslie, do you think that's
a nice partner to have ‐‐
someone who wants to squeeze
a woman's head?
I don't want to see you
taken advantage of.
‐Wow!
‐Really, it's not.
Okay, Leslie,
you got three offers.
John:
Hold on one second.
I absolutely know
that Lori
is great for this deal,
of course, right?
I didn't think about
that point with Shutterfly.
And then me ‐‐ I want to sell or
license or work with ShurTech,
the ones who do all
the Duck Tape in the world.
So I think those are
our unique selling propositions.
Lori, would you be interested
in teaming up
with either Daymond
or Mr. Wonderful?
Wow, Lori's not
enough for you?
I don't really need to team up
with either of them.
None of us need each other
on this one.
The important thing,
Leslie,
is that when my entrepreneurs
do a deal with me, they get me.
I'm the one that's on the phone
with them.
I'm the one that's doing
the designing of the packaging
and helping them to get
everything done.
Does she look like someone
who didn't do their homework,
who doesn't see us
all with our entrepreneurs?
She knows who does it.
I'm just telling you
I'm not gonna ever speak ‐‐
I have great respect
for my fellow Sharks.
Leslie, do not give up 20%.
That's very foolish.
But I do not ever speak
for what they do,
as they shouldn't speak
for what I do.
‐Right. Exactly.
‐I can only tell you what I do.
Daymond will do it for 15%.
I'll do it for 10%.
And I'm a good partner.
‐So start squeezing.
‐Isn't that obnoxious?
‐It is! It is!
‐Not at all.
‐But I love him.
‐This is the Shark Tank, Leslie.
‐Reject his offer.
‐This happens in the Shark Tank.
Just because ‐‐
All right, 20% is
a bit much equity for me.
‐Way too much.
‐What's your counter?
So my counter is would you be
open to $100,000 loan for 10%?
If I don't repay you
in the first year, you get 20%.
You got it.
‐Done.
Whoo!
[ Laughs ]
Leslie, you made me an offer
I couldn't refuse.
We will be
a dynamite team.
We will.
We really will.
We're gonna take this
to be huge.
I'm gonna ‐‐ Anyway, bye.
Bye!
[ Laughter ]
Whoo!
Oh, my God!
I did it, did it, did it!
She's just
way too mellow.
Yeah, she doesn't have
any energy.
La, la, la, la, la!
Yes!
[ Grunting ]
If you're at home watching
and you have an idea,
trust your crazy idea,
and then hustle, hustle, hustle
to make it happen.
Narrator: In Season 7,
we watched Matt Alexander
and Mike Kannely
secure a deal with Kevin O'Leary
for their prototype
toilet‐bowl light IllumiBowl.
Kannely: IllumiBowl
is a motion‐activated,
toilet‐bowl night‐light.
I'll give you 100 grand for 25%.
‐You got a deal, Kevin.
‐Yeah.
Narrator: Let's see what they're
doing now.
Kannely: Okay, guys,
we've got two more hours
to get all of these out.
Let's go!
Before "Shark Tank," we only had
$100,000 in pre‐orders.
We had to do everything
in my spare bedroom.
We didn't even have product
made yet.
Making a deal with Kevin
allowed us to fill
all our orders
and really push
our brand forward.
Not only did we get
our first retailer,
but we got into
Bed Bath & Beyond nationwide.
It's only been
a few months,
and we're already at over
$7 million in sales.
IllumiBowl,
Mr. Wonderful is here!
‐Yeah!
‐Hey, Kevin!
O'Leary:
This company is exploding.
They've got into
Bed Bath & Beyond,
and it's selling through
like hot cakes.
If we're gonna make this
the number‐one way
to light up a toilet bowl
in America,
it has to be 10 times
bigger than this.
You got to ramp up
production.
You've got to blanket
the entire market.
It's really important now
that they get to the other big
boxes ‐‐ Walmart, Walgreens.
They've got to get to every
single retailer,
and I want my team
to help them get there.
I love you guys.
‐[ Both laugh ]
I think we're getting close.
[ Chuckles ]
Oh, man.
I've done a lot
of "Shark Tank" deals.
It's really rare when a couple
of entrepreneurs
like Mike and Matt
blow it up so big so fast.
Next stop ‐‐
world domination toilets.
We're gonna flush away
the competition.
"Shark Tank" has really changed
our lives.
We're lighting up toilets,
but we're also creating jobs,
and we're inspiring people to do
more with their lives.
With the growth
of IllumiBowl,
our aim is to turn this into
a $50 million company.
This is
our American dream.
All: IllumiBowl!
[ Sighs ]
‐Let's do it!
‐Thanks, bud.
Producer:
Five seconds to the doors.
4, 3, 2, 1.
Narrator:
Next up is an entrepreneur
capitalizing
on a new trend in eating.
Hello, Sharks!
Whoo!
I'm so glad to be here.
My name is Nick Massie.
I live in Truckee, California.
I'm the Chief Culinary Ninja
at Ice Age Meals.
And I'm seeking $1 million in
exchange for 10% of my company.
$1 million?
$1 million.
Whoo!
To debunk the myths you've been
fed about nutrition
and show you the truth
about food is my mission.
[ Chuckles ]
To illustrate this,
I've written a poem.
This is called
"The Ice Age is Here."
It's the diet of the cavemen
who surely did eat it,
and if you try it out,
you'll be tempted to cheat it.
Thanks to the cardboard box,
cooking skills
have been blunted.
But cavemen didn't have
this problem, why?
Because they gathered
and hunted.
The obesity train is on a roll.
The brakes are broken.
It's out of control.
Time is now more valuable
than ever.
We've got planning and shopping
and cooking and dishes.
It's like we need a genie to
come grant our meal‐prep wishes.
Now, I don't have a shiny lamp.
What I've got is a simple
cardboard box with ice
that brings meals to your door
at a reasonable price.
So come with me,
and the goods you'll witness ‐‐
Let Paleo Nick be your guide
to culinary fitness.
[ Laughter ]
Wow.
I've got some samples
I'd like to hand out.
This is our butternut squash
lasagna.
It's our top seller.
Thank you.
Oh!
‐That's delicious.
‐That's great.
‐Really good.
‐Very good.
‐Thank you.
‐Is this your recipe?
This is.
Greiner: You said you're
the culinary ninja.
‐Massie: Culinary ninja.
‐That's really good.
You are the chef for all
of the meals that you ship?
‐This is great.
‐I am.
So, tell us about you. And this
is delicious, by the way.
Well, Nick, before you get
going into it,
will you hand us the packaging
so we can look at
the nutritional...?
Massie:
Yeah, let me do that.
How many calories
is in this?
All of our meals
are around 500 calories.
‐So this one plate is 500?
‐This one meal is 500?
No, that's about 1/3 portion
right there.
What is the Paleo diet?
The Paleo diet is meat
and vegetables, nuts and seeds,
some fruit, little starch,
and no sugar.
All of our meals
are $9.99.
‐Okay, so this is $9.99.
‐Yeah.
What does it cost you
to make this?
That cost me $2.95.
Herjavec: How long have you been
selling the product?
The product has been selling
since August of last year.
What have the sales been?
$1.5 million.
Wow.
What did you do
this past month?
We did $130,000.
And you are delivering
all over the country.
All 50 states. Correct.
What's your minimum ‐‐
How many meals?
So, if you want to buy
12 meals,
you pay $120
plus $20 shipping.
Okay, so, $140.
Why is that worth
$10 million?
Before Kevin
asks his question ‐‐
Why is that worth
$10 million?
Before we get to that,
I want to know a little bit
about your story.
Yeah, let me tell you
my story.
This was delicious.
This is delicious, right?
‐Yeah, it's really good.
‐You went to culinary school.
I did go
to culinary school.
From there, I got a degree in
hotel and restaurant management.
And a minor in Spanish.
[ Laughter ]
Which makes perfect sense.
I ultimately got a job
at Aspen, Colorado,
where I eventually became
the chef for Lance Armstrong.
So from 2008 to 2011 ‐‐
So, it's your fault.
[ Chuckles ]
No, I'm ‐‐ I have
nothing to do with that.
My first day, he was doing some
CrossFit training at the time,
and I was inspired.
Did my first workout
October 30, 2008,
never looked back, and started
meshing my two passions.
Do you have a deal with CrossFit
to use their name?
Yes and no.
You guys ready for this?
Yesterday they flew me
to Santa Cruz
to meet with
their chief operating officer,
the head of their business.
So is this why you're valuing
the business where you're at?
Correct.
Because based on
this future business
that you think
you're gonna have?
Do you actually have a written
agreement with CrossFit
that gives you the right
to market under their name?
I don't have a written
agreement.
We would essentially be
their co‐packer.
We don't have the details.
‐Why's it worth $10 million?
So you're gonna ‐‐ Wait,
I want to ask a question.
Have they given you an offer,
though, that is firm?
They have ‐‐ This is very recent
and very fast‐moving.
Herjavec: So, Nick, let's just
leave that alone
'cause it's very preliminary.
‐Right.
Talk to me a little bit
about the story, in your mind,
of how you got to this value
of $10 million.
The valuation ‐‐
I mean, I see right now ‐‐
This is
a $1‐billion business.
‐That's the answer?
‐What's a $1‐billion business?
Yes.
What, this is gonna be
a $1‐billion business?
‐Yes.
‐Uh, Ice Age Meals?
Yeah.
Why?
Because [groans] I mean...
"Why is it gonna be
a $1‐billion business?"
Cuban: Please
tell us this one.
I mean, so, we modeled this
after an existing company.
Which one?
Amy's.
You guys know Amy's Organics?
‐Yeah, of course.
‐Right.
They started in 1988.
So they're 28 years into it.
But Amy's sells
into grocery stores.
Yeah.
Are you planning on putting this
into grocery stores
or just doing
direct‐to‐consumer?
Yeah, all across the board.
I can do that same model.
I know I can, but with meat.
They're 100% vegetarian.
‐Nick, I just ‐‐
‐You've studied Amy's, then.
Yeah, yes.
You've really moved me, and I
want to read a poem, okay?
‐Oh!
‐Oh, no.
I really want to ‐‐
I want to read a poem,
and I've written it for you.
‐That's a special moment.
‐It doesn't happen very often.
"In cash I know because
I like to watch it flow.
When I ask valuation,
I want no hesitation.
Are you worth $10 million?
Hell, no."
[ Laughter ]
‐Kevin.
‐Damn, Kevin.
How is it possible that any
of these other four Sharkettes
are gonna figure out
to do a deal with you
where they have to own
more than 100%?
They're gonna believe in me.
‐Nick ‐‐
‐That's the answer?
Yeah.
‐I'm out.
‐Okay.
Nick, I love the story.
I love the name.
‐How is this still gonna happen?
‐I love everything.
‐We're getting there.
‐I love the questions.
I hate the valuation.
‐You don't say, Robert?
‐I know you do.
‐You've got a problem.
‐But you love me.
Robert, you love me, don't you?
I find $10 million
a little rich.
‐How about $1 million's rich?
‐I do love you, Nick!
Yes! Whoo!
‐Whoo!
‐[ Laughs ]
This right here ‐‐ Listen.
Corporate wellness program.
Huh? We just planted
one of these freezers.
A guy shows up.
‐Can I just tell you?
‐Yeah.
If I was ever in a meeting
and we were talking business
and you came back to me
and said, "Huh?!"
it would be over
right there.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm out.
Are you nervous
right now?
You guys ‐‐
I'm not nervous.
‐You're not nervous at all?
‐I love all you guys except ‐‐
I mean ‐‐
‐Wait a second, Nick.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐There's the, "Huh?!"
Just because I tell
the truth.
I'm the only Shark
telling the truth here.
Herjavec:
So, Nick, I love the story.
I love the name.
Hate the value.
It's insane.
Ohh!
I'm out.
O'Leary:
Okay, Daymond.
Your poem, please.
‐Oh, boy, here it comes.
‐Another poem?
"Roses are red,
and I am black."
[ Laughter ]
"Your valuation was whack.
So I don't know how
to say this with tact.
I'm out."
Now there's only
one Shark left.
Lori, Lori, what are
you going to do?
Lori.
Greiner:
You know you came in here ‐‐
You asked for a huge amount
of money.
I know.
I understand that.
Without having that paper
in your hand that said,
"I have
this $5 million deal."
‐Even that. Too much.
‐That's the problem.
It was just too high.
‐I understand.
I'm out.
‐Okay, guys.
‐Congratulations.
‐Thank you so much.
‐Yeah, thank you. Thank you.
‐Good luck.
Hey, hey?
Huh, huh, huh, huh?!
‐Yeah.
‐Huh?! Huh?!
But it's just the way
the guy is.
Come on, we're not all polished
and slick like you.
I'm certainly not polished.
Maybe slick,
but it's like rubbing your
fingers on a chalkboard.
It would have
driven me nuts.
I'm Jeff.
And this is
my 17‐year‐old son, Jack.
And we're from Mandeville,
Louisiana.
Jack and I have been
fishing together
since he was one year old.
I could cast a fishing pole
before I could even walk,
but that certainly doesn't
mean that we're experts.
Oops.
[ Chuckles ]
We've had too many trips where
we came home empty‐handed.
There had to be a way that
we could catch more fish.
So we invented it.
Jack has always been
an exceptionally bright kid.
And he is really the driving
force behind this business.
Instead of going out with
friends, I stay at home working.
I built the website, the
prototyping, the engineering.
Ohh!
We know that we need to get into
the big retail fishing stores.
‐That was a huge gar fish.
‐Ohh!
We can't get them
to take our calls.
‐Wow!
‐Whoo!
I put in $75,000 to get
this business started.
‐Whoo!
‐Whoo! Yeah!
This is real money.
This is real lives.
This is real people.
It has to succeed.
Bye‐bye, big guy.
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Jack Danos.
And my name
is Jeff Danos.
We're a father‐son team from
Mandeville, Louisiana.
We're seeking $150,000 in return
for 10% of our company.
We're the inventors
of the TactiBite Fish Call.
"What's a Fish Call,"
you ask?
Well, it's like a duck call,
but for fish.
You see, the two of us
have been on countless
fishing trips together,
and even though my dad claimed
to be an expert fisherman,
the truth is on plenty of trips,
we really didn't do so well.
Now, come on, Jack.
You know that I've always been
the fish master.
[ Chuckling ]
Whatever you say, Dad.
So, anyways, we came up
with a way to help my dad
and all of the other
"fish masters" out there
catch more fish.
The TactiBite Fish Call
works by sending out
sounds and vibrations that
attract predator and game fish.
You simply turn it on, toss it
out, and cast around it.
This is what
the fish hear.
[ High‐pitched rattling ]
And they can't help
but head towards it
in search
of their next meal.
It's affordable, compact,
and, yes, it really works.
We already know that this thing
works on fish.
Now we want to see if it will
attract the Sharks.
So, tell us about your business.
How much have you sold?
‐Can we see the product?
‐Wait, can we see it?
So, essentially,
that sound that we heard...
‐Yes.
‐... that attracts the fish?
Yes.
It makes them think
other fish are feeding.
That's correct.
[ High‐pitched rattling ]
And that is our
"scared shrimp" sound.
Scared shrimp?
[ Laughter ]
Both: Exactly.
Do shrimp
really make sound?
Yeah, so, it will.
[ Low‐pitched rattling ]
Oh, it makes multiple
different sounds.
Depending on the fish
that you are going after.
Automated voice: Sound number
one ‐‐ scared shrimp.
"Sound number one ‐‐
scared shrimp."
What is sound number two?
So, that's called
"rattle battle,"
and you can hit ‐‐
That's it right there.
So, we found that freshwater
fish really like that sound.
So, how many more fish
do you find you catch
by throwing this
into the water
versus when you went out
on a normal fishing day?
We used to be the guys
who would go out,
and whenever we'd come back,
we'd talk to other people about
how many they caught.
And we'd always catch
less than other people.
So now,
when we go back in,
we almost always have caught
more fish than the other people.
Can I just get
a technical description
of exactly how I use it?
This is the anchor.
So, when you toss it out,
this sinks down...
Yeah.
... and this stays on the top,
so it holds it in place.
Have you sold any?
‐Yes.
‐Great question.
So, we're glad
you asked this question.
Yes‐s‐s.
We've been selling these
for five months,
and we've already sold $330,000
worth of it.
‐Yes‐s.
‐What?
What do you sell it for?
It sells online
for $99.99.
‐Really?
‐Yes.
‐And what's the cost landed?
‐$16 landed.
‐What?!
‐Nice.
‐Yeah.
‐Oh, my gosh.
Jack, are you in school?
What's your background?
So, I'm 17.
I'm home‐schooled.
‐You're only 17?
‐We get that all the time.
I thought you were 22.
‐Jack has been ‐‐
‐I thought you were like 32.
Well, he's been exposed
to business all of his life.
Herjavec:
So, Jack, every Shark up here
is an expert at something.
There's one Shark up here that
is an absolute expert fisherman.
Who do you think that is?
I think it's Daymond.
We would bet
it's Daymond.
You are the fish master.
Will this work?
How would I know
if it would work?
Well, what do you think?
You're a fisherman.
‐He never used it before.
‐The noise ‐‐ Would it work?
Have you ever used
a fishing lure
that has a rattler
that makes sound?
Yeah, I use poppers,
rattles, all of them.
‐Exactly.
All right, so,
let's say a popper.
It's going into the water.
This is not going to
give a motion
to make the fish
jerk and react.
So, it doesn't make, like,
a splashing in the water,
but it does
simulate that.
Fish have what's called lateral
lines that run down both sides,
and it's basically
like our ears.
They have little hairs
that feel sounds
and vibrations
in the water.
And so they feel
something.
They feel like it feels
like a school of fish
or, you know,
prey that's injured,
and they head towards it.
How much inventory
do you have?
‐We just ‐‐
‐$500,000 worth.
Wow! Where'd you get
the money for that?
‐Wow.
‐Daddy.
That was actually all
paid for by ‐‐
So, our first order
was 3,000 units.
So, yeah, 'cause your costs
are so low,
you were able to buy them
for $85,000.
We sold those,
and we bought the next 6,000
just on the money
we had in the bank.
So you paid
for all that inventory.
‐Yes.
‐We own it.
So, with that inventory,
why don't you back yourself?
You have the money.
The reason that we wanted to
bring a Shark onboard
is because we know
what you can do.
We know that you can get us
into retail stores,
and we know that you can
just make it explode.
O'Leary: Okay, a little nervous
about the $99.
I'm thinking more
$69, $79 for them.
But, you know,
10%'s not enough
to get me out of the water,
I think.
It's too light.
So I'm gonna say I'll do
$150,000 for 20%.
Before we go cutting
our valuation,
I'd just like to explain how we
got there with the valuation.
‐Sure. Fire away.
‐That's fair. Go ahead.
So, so far this year, we've done
$330,000 in five months.
So this year, we will do ‐‐
If we just stay on track,
we'll do over $750,000.
On that, we'll net
at least $300,000.
And so what we did is we took
a 5x multiple on that,
and that got us
to $1.5 million.
That's a good call.
Jack, you are the freakiest,
smartest 17‐year‐old
in the world.
Thank you.
Okay, guys, let me tell you
something, Jack.
The way I look at it is,
99 bucks may not play,
and they may not put and give it
shelf space on that basis.
I don't know that yet.
We're all gonna learn that
together.
Other Sharks may give you
a better valuation,
but for me,
it feels right at 20%.
‐Your valuation's fair.
‐Okay.
John: I think your valuation
is fair, as well.
Reading
in between the lines is,
there's gonna be expected work
on our side,
besides capital,
and that's time.
So I'm gonna match
Kevin O'Leary's offer,
and I just want you to choose me
over him at the equal value
so we can screw him
together.
[ Chuckles ]
All right, guys, look,
I just want to show you
something very important.
Just as you think.
I don't often bring this out.
This is very important.
He's gonna make your money
disappear.
Mr. Wonderful
is open for business.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Ooh!
‐We love that.
‐Exactly.
And that's very special.
Very special.
Okay, so, guys, since you have
all these hard‐core fishermen,
and the only thing that I fish
for is money and deals,
this isn't something for me.
So I'm out.
‐Okay. Thank you for your time.
‐Thank you.
I know fishermen will do
anything to catch fish.
‐We all want to catch fish.
‐And it's a passion.
I don't think I've seen
any sport
as passionate
as fishermen.
I like this because
some of the most popular
infomercial products
were fishing products.
Really?
That's the world
that I'm really in.
‐Okay.
‐I love TV sales.
I love the infomercial world.
I have great partners.
I see this as being able
to blow it up
by doing a great infomercial
with it
so that people can see
how it works.
Yes.
Lori, are you in an interview,
or are you making an offer?
‐I'm making an offer.
‐Before we die.
Okay, I'll give you
$150,000 for 15%.
Thank you for your offer.
Better offer.
Can I just ‐‐
Can I ask why you ‐‐
Like, what ‐‐ Do you feel like
our valuation is too high?
Like, what ‐‐
I think everybody agreed that
we were at a fair valuation.
You know what you guys are
running into,
and it's very simple ‐‐
When you actually get a Shark
as an investor,
that's extremely valuable.
We've learned that
over the years,
and I don't do that
for free.
That's why I have
this plaque.
‐That plaque.
‐It's expensive.
What I would like
to counter ‐‐
Lori, would you do $200,000
for the 15%?
Narrator:
One Shark is out.
Jack and Jeffrey have
three offers on the table
for their fish baiter
TactiBite Fish Call.
And they've made a counteroffer
to Lori.
Would you do $200,000
for the 15%?
No.
I know with my Simply Fit Board
infomercial we just did, right,
I probably put personally
150 hours into it
from editing it, producing it,
the script, everything.
I don't think your brand
is fishing, Lori.
I got to tell you.
‐It was really ‐‐
My brand is product.
I don't care
if it's fishing or a tutu.
It doesn't matter to me.
You're that good
at everything, Lori?
O'Leary: I just don't
think your brand is fish.
How chauvinistic
are you?
‐Very.
‐Thank you, Daymond.
Here's my thing
about Lori.
I think she's great
at what she does, right?
‐Has everybody made an offer?
‐Not yet.
‐We haven't ‐‐
‐Oh, Robert.
We're not sure
if we've ‐‐
We'd like to hear
if you have an offer.
You've thrown some chum
into the water.
We have.
They're hearing ‐‐
The Sharks are hearing the call,
I believe.
Absolutely.
You know, I find it
very interesting
that every Shark told you
your valuation is fair.
How often do we ask that
question on the show?
How rarely does somebody give us
a good answer for that?
I love the story.
I love your sales.
I like the offer you made.
‐Okay.
I'll give you
the $150,000,
and I'll give it to you
for the 10%.
I'll give it to you
‐Ohh!
‐I won't give it to you for 10%.
Because I don't like him
doing that.
Doing what?
I will ‐‐ Because you're sitting
there lecturing them.
Doing what?
John: Guys, let me say, I'm not
gonna counter against Robert.
I'm gonna stay
where I'm at.
I want to ask you
a question.
How many times do you think
each one of these Sharks
go fishing a month?
‐I would be lying if I guessed.
‐Greiner: Admittedly, I do not.
I go fishing a month
about six times.
‐Do you?
‐He does.
‐Yeah, he really does fish.
‐So I live this.
See, while he's fishing,
I'm working at making
our guys money.
But that's a whole
different thing.
Yeah, when I'm fishing,
my money's making me money.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐I'm gonna tell you this.
So I'm letting you know
that's where I stand,
and I'm gonna allow them
to fight.
Mine is $150,000 for 10%.
But I'd like you to answer now.
So, I'm not gonna wait
for Robert.
Just one question ‐‐
Would you be interested
in partnering with Robert
for the same $150,000 for 10%?
No, because
I don't need Robert.
I know I'm the one that's gonna
be doing all of the work.
She didn't offer you
the right amount of
money at the beginning.
He doesn't know how to do
an infomercial.
She's reacting,
as she always does,
to what's happening
in the water.
We all know how to do
infomercials.
Robert did this
the other day.
I'm not fighting
for Robert,
but we all know how
to do infomercials.
I'm not
gonna deal with it.
‐It's ridiculous.
‐I believe in you.
I think you're great.
I'd like you to take my offer.
And I respect if you don't.
When I'm buying
a tractor‐supply company,
she's gonna be selling
earrings.
I respect Lori. You don't need
two Sharks on this.
Look, I gave you
what you wanted.
$150,000 for 10%.
Robert, we would love
to accept your offer.
‐Bang.
‐Let's go fishing!
‐Whoo! Let's go! Come on!
‐Let's go!
‐I'll go fishing now!
Yeah!
Oh, my God.
Thank you.
‐Thank you, guys.
‐Good luck.
‐Thank you.
‐Whoo!
‐Come on.
All right!
That was awesome.
We did it.
To see those guys stand up there
and say that,
"Jack, you've got to be
the smartest 17‐year‐old kid
that I've ever met" ‐‐
There's just nothing
like it.
Well, I guess
I'm taking this back.
[ Laughter ]
I'm gonna put it back
and bring it out later.